今が6敗とございません
がんばれこちらは順調です皆さん着ぐるみよく見たことありませんかイベントとか
催し物があるとえばこの子どもたちがキュって喜ぶた眠い着ぐるみ着てる人がいるん
ですよな彼は人間ですね結構着ぐるみ着てるので大きかったりするんですよ中に人間が
入ってるで中に人間が入ってるで大きかったりするんですけどもすごい
ん
年か
着ぐるみてー
怖くない着ぐるみはかわいいなぁかわいいですけどもなんかかわいいだしたない有様目
の多くが闇みたいなやつ北あると思うんですよ着ぐるみ怖いですよ実は
というわけで今日はアマゾンでよりすぐりのあのパッと見ておりが本の手にヤバイって
いう感じた着ぐるみ買ったのでそれを今から開いていきたいとおもいます
梱包雑こんなに入ってるんですけども
ちょっと決起グラビたと戦車を取るなんですね
ちょっとこれがさっほーこれが顔ですねー
[音楽]
闇を感じるこれが顔です
はから足足でちょっと1回マジで来てみようと思いますこれ一人できるの
どういう水井ぞ
まぁ絶対もう上でねー汗もちゃんとついてのもう結構本格的なよ出産しです
こうしておおぉでこうしてこうしてこう
どうですかいや問わずなるを怖いと思ったけどこれ
やっぱり強いと思ってこれ風につい今日の動画はこの状態で4割9分言う前にずーっと
様と思いますそれでずっといいですよめっちゃ濃いと思うんですよ
皇帝撤兵しちゃう
ポップな可愛さ重水な可愛いしちゃってホラーと思うんでこれちょっと
ターゲットの言う前にしばらく行ってみようと思いますでは
[音楽]
はぁ
バッハ
うん
ん
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
th
ん
can you do
me
[音楽]
ん
いい
[音楽]
入ったよじゃーんっ
ええええええ
[音楽]